so from looking at your IMDB pages I see
that you both have done a few docks
before what lessons did you take from
those prior documentaries that you use
toward this one the good and the bad hmm
interesting because you've been through
the trenches before what did you know
this time that we either have to do this
or don't do this that's an interesting
question i think my first film was
called dr. bronner's magic soap box and
um one thing that I learned was that it
takes a really long time to make a
documentary so I definitely had a sense
of like okay if we're gonna start on
this it's gonna take a while like I feel
like I had like a very solid
understanding of the fact that it was
going to take a long time then I didn't
have that the first time and I also
think that I had a very I don't know
realistic is the right word but it was
it was not a lot of expectations about
you know how the film was gonna like get
swooped up by the the powers that be and
run off and become the next greatest
thing and make us millions of dollars
like I was like that's not the reality
of being like a working documentary
filmmaker today and so I think my
experience with that film really helped
us to to set up for example start
building our audience the moment you
start shooting which is what we did and
that was because with dr. bronner's what
I realized is that oh there's this huge
market out there everybody uses dr.
bronner's magic soaps they'll be this
great audience but I didn't the tools
weren't the same and at that time I mean
that I was working in the early two
thousands of like Facebook didn't exist
you know but but I knew that there was a
huge market but there were but it was
too late like you can't make the film
and then connect with your audience
there's too much work that has to happen
in order to have that you know presence
already and so we we really talked about
start talking about the film like
basically after that first trip with IMA
we got our Facebook page up and running
and like started trying to get people to
talk about it um and I think that was
probably the number one lesson that I
that I learned was like you're gonna
have to build your audience and don't
don't waste any time doing it I remember
we were driving to a birth with ina Mae
and Sarah was on her phone we were like
in the middle of Tennessee on the
highway and she had written that we were
on the way to the birth and there was a
picture of my anime like in the car and
there were people from all over the
world like sending their blessings and I
think that was a moment when I realized
the power of it and that we were
connecting with people in Brazil and
Germany and they were all sending their
you know greetings and support and
that's I think it was a hard thing for
me in the beginning I was like why are
we connecting with people we don't even
know what's going to happen with this
film what if we you know it felt like
this extra added pressure of like what
if we don't god forbid we don't finish
the film and like then we have this you
know it felt so new and so unfamiliar to
me to reach out while you're really in
the incubator of making something which
I've always found like I've done in
isolation whether you're collaborating
on a film or not but you don't share
anything until your rough cut and so I I
fought against it I was like I don't
want to do that that doesn't feel right
and and I was completely wrong and it
took some time to I'm not very much time
but I just remember that moment feeling
like oh this is a really amazing thing
and this feels really good to have all
these strangers rooting for us and so
just to add to what you said about the
social media part i mean ya know
I had no idea the power of it and I
think that it was just beginning like
four years ago or three years ago when
we started doing it that is when people
were starting to realize that they had
to connect with their audiences
immediately so it feels really good to
be sort of like having done it doing the
most modern thing you can do that
filmmaker you know we've kind of
surprised ourselves like building a
player on our on our own website to play
the film and you know we've really tried
to look forward what are the best tools
for independent filmmakers right now and
not relying on the old way where you
sell it for a really nominal fee and
it's out of your hands like how do we
what how will more and more people see
it and and how do we connect with our
audience and how do we get them to
support us and how do we support them
and share our work with them so that's
been a black hair aside a big deal that
was completely new yeah and also that's
just after the last documentary is that
I was like I'll never make another
documentary again and then of course
it's it's it's an impractical um career
you know and you figure out ways in
between to make it all work but you know
it's really like you have to love what
you're doing and I just love these women
and I love being around them and I felt
like if this is going to take me away
from my family at certain times I it has
to be something that's meaningful and
principled and will make the world a
better place and I think we both felt
that way and it felt like this was good
work to be doing and this might help
women and
families and this might help dr. see a
different way and midwives and doulas
and anyone you know like when we
premiered the film at LA Film Festival
and the programmer was like this is a
film about humanity and I was like that
seems pretty intense I was like okay you
know um anyways so if you're going to
make the commitment to make a film have
it be something that you you have to
make the film we had to make this film
there wasn't really like a question you
know it was like when we set out it was
like yeah we're going to do this because
this is important it kind of fell in our
laps in a little in some way so um it
just felt like one day we were making
the film and it had to be made and we
would have people to make it so it
sounds like that's how you temper your
expectations and that you were so taken
by the process and everyone that you met
that even if nothing happened with it
you were still going to be semi okay
because you just met these wonderful
people and stories inspired you well I'm
I'm not sure because I think that you
can only make a film if you're sure
something will happen with it I mean
there's too much work you know that goes
into it but I think the difference is
you're going to make something happen
with it right it's not like I'm going to
sit around and wait for something to
happen with my film something is going
to happen with it because I'm going to
do all the things that need to happen in
order to make something happen with it
do you know what I mean it's sort of a
subtle distinction but i think but i
think the um i guess it's just I it just
seems like critical to sort of remind
ourselves that like we ultimately are
responsible for the for the destiny of
our films within it within a certain
within certain very realistic parameters
if that makes sense yeah it does i think
so so so not sort of this fatalistic
idea well it's meant to be
other than it will but then also knowing
that don't count your eggs before they
hatch but also still that you are gonna
put in the effort and build that
audience ahead of time and really can
idea sounds like that was your God and
work hard every day and figure out how
to finish film and you know make it the
best it can be yeah it's very hard but
it's been super satisfying as it goes
out into the world I wonder if there's a
part of like because I I definitely
identified to with what Mary was saying
about like how challenging it is to
start like connecting with your audience
when you don't even know what it is that
you're doing yet um and and that
happened and that has its own impact on
the work that you're making as well for
good and like you know there's some
discomfort in that as well but I also
wonder if like that you've made a
promise in a way that like you can't go
back on I'm can't you there's no choice
but sit but to get it done I got it done
as well as she probably part of the fear
i think i probably had its like I mean I
always finish things that I begin but I
feel like that is part of it is that
you're indebted now now you've set it
out loud we're going to be out doing
this thing and so it has to be as real
as yeah real can get
you